[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une nouvelle
arme
écoutez je veux vous parler de l'arme de
demain
enfant du monde elle en sera la fin je
veux vous
parler de
moi de
vous je vois à l'intérieur des images
des couleurs qui ne sont pas à moi qui
parfois me font peur
sensation qui peuvent me rendre fou
nos sens sont nos fils ns pauvres
marionnette nous sensons le chemin qui
mène droit à nos tête la peau humaine tu
la tient dans ta main tu as détonateur
juste à côté du cœur la bombe humaine
c'est toi elle
t'appartient si tu laisses quelqu'un
prendre en main ton destin c'est la
fin h la
[Musique]
fin la
fin mon père ne d plus sans prendre ses
calmentants maman ne travaille plus sans
ses excitants quelqu'un leur vend de
quoi
[Musique]
tenir je suis un électron bombardé de
protons le rythme de la ville c'est ça
mon vrai patron je suis
chargé
[Musique]
d'électricité au cœur de l' orateur je
rencontre une particule qui met de
sahumeur vudrait pas que je me laisse
aller faudrait pas que que je me laisse
aller vrais pas que je me laisse
aller vra voudrais pas que me laisse
aller je me laisse aller
vrezvous que que je me laisse
allerre que je me laisse
aller la pom humaine c'est l'arme de
demain ené du monde elle en sera la fin
la bombe humaine c'est toi elle
t'appartient si tu la un quelqu'un prend
en main ton dessin c'est la
fin to tiens tu as des donateur juste à
côté du cœur un bon met tu la tiens dans
ta main tu laisses quelqu'un prendre en
main ton
espace Pourain c'est l'arme de
demain tu as des donateurs juste à pe du
cœur pour humain tu la tiens dans ta
main si tu laisses quelqu'un prendre en
main ton destin c'est la c'est l'arme de
demain
laau tu la tiens dans ta main la et Noi
t'appartient tu laisses quelqu'un pendre
ton destin c'est
Laumain c'est l'arme de
demainum
c'estartient ta humain tu la tient dans
ta main si tu laisses VI pr à ton destin
c'est l' P c'est l'arme de domain la p
tu là tient dans ta main un pon B c'est
toi elle
t'appartient tu quel dans un bon destin
c'est l' bon c'est l'arme de demain la
bon hum tu la tiens dans sa m la B c'est
toi ma ah que je laisse aller que je
laisse
[Musique]
all